hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to ultimate epic battle
simulator now I can't believe I'm back
again I didn't think it happened but I
find this game to be incredibly
intriguing I mean it's very simple on
its surface and there's only so much
that you can do about it but I'm kind of
like kind of like just curious oh that's
boring a flat test map no way alright
we're gonna go in the world the thieves
here and I'm gonna I'm gonna make sure
my wild man is still there in the forest
over there but I'm gonna have some
different things going on here let's see
now more animals we need oh hell yeah
catapults how many catapults could we
possibly have 5000 that seems good
enough to me we need to assault this
castle somehow who's gonna stop them
well I guess we're gonna have a fortress
of evil or we're gonna have a fortress
of or a dwarf fortress if you may call
it that if you please but I won't
because I'm not we can do more dwarves
than that 'we can do more dwarves and
they're gonna be defending well they're
gonna stop with the catapults but I
guess that's gonna be good enough so we
got 10,000 dwarves strong in the air
now we're gonna have you anymore no
Wildman this time inanimate dresser
let's see what five thousand dressers
look like when they're attacking this
guy and the wild man over there dressers
they can retarget like the thing you put
clothes in that's what we're talking
about right we're not just talking about
a bunch of [ __ ] we're talking about
literally look little they're talking
about dressers look at the d'oeuvres
oh hey dorms eat hey door Vosges whoa
that's a lot of d'oeuvres oh hey bud hey
buddy hey hey guys all right okay
they're doing their thing I gotta figure
out where the hell these dressers are
that's all on a door it's just uh there
are their dressers their dressers
against oh my god that's a lot of cata
bolts I wanna possess this guy hey can I
just watch this from afar oh man
being a wild man sure is great I love it
to death kill ya no I'm not okay oh yeah
that one's go wild man you go you go if
I come back and find out that you're
dead I'm gonna be very disappointed Oh
oh it's a massacre oh it's a massacre of
dressers all those poor dressers these
[ __ ] screaming inanimate objects for
some reason the foam man
Oh mamma jamma oh god that's terrifying
[Applause]
single file like that killed a few of
you you bastard
it's so silly why is it so silly I gotta
get it let's uh let's get the time scale
up there that's the good stuff
is that too tight this is at two times
speed look at we're going out of my mind
here well here we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna be got one of these dresses
and I might become with these you go my
faithful steed how do you even attack
what is your what is your attack here
what are you trying to accomplish I'm
gonna flank them or come up the side
they'll never know you coming for you
yeah Oh trust me try me try you tried
beat you trust me these dorms doors
doors
oh man the catapults have moved in they
are not happy
oh but the dorms have the high ground
Wow Wow are you okay oh please tell me
wild man's okay my sweet boy man oh it's
so very extremely bad okay fine then man
I wish I could be [ __ ] man
I wish I could beat them up real good
real good
Oh
Oh God Oh
[Applause]
they're just dying which is great hey
guys how you doing you catching face
full of oh well this guy is impenetrable
over here you'll never hit me
you can hit me
as I leave the screams of the Damned
over there we're gonna try this once
more this is so fun I don't know why is
this fun I have no idea all right we're
gonna go into the desert because I want
a nice clear new new kind day all right
let me figure this out clear all these
we need some fresh blood here
all right make something that's like ooh
whoa golden Knight and Chuck Norris can
we have golden Knight and Chuck Norris
fighting out on a beach I don't even
know what that's gonna mean but there
there there we go it's a clash of titans
it's a battle of immeasurable power it's
it's a it's a battle of the greatest
forces this world has ever known and oh
my god this map is much bigger than I
thought let's we've got the golden
Knight Chuck Norris and oh what's that
over the crest of the hill Wow all right
we're gonna start this bad boy oh that's
funny all right yeah we need to turn
cinematic mode on for this and enable
this bad boy here waiting I want that
many wild men oh wait hang on cut that
part out I didn't goof just one wild man
please we didn't we don't need 250 of
them there's only well I needs to bear
100 yeah it started me out on the right
guy
wild man will feast on the blood of your
own blood today
okay anyway how's it going golden night
you okay you good oh yeah you're good
all right let's see oh hey how's it
going Chucky how's it whoa Chuck Norris
you have I'm not the only one who
notices this doesn't look a goddamn
thing like Chuck Norris right that
that's not just me this this literally
is not Chuck Norris right not the only
one there
we need cinematic mode on this bad boy
oh there they go and here comes wild man
oh boy how could you you killed him you
killed my son okay let's get a real
legit battle I want a legit battle I
want a legit one clear it out here clear
it out here let's go overdue ah this
looks like a good murder bull right here
we're gonna build ah I don't even know
what ranked shape means unit customized
boom
can Imay go wild Oh mainly block chins
oh then projectile he shoots bullets
his nipples he's a woman with guns for
nipples oh man he's got so much health
50,000 he does 500 damages swing it kid
you get you for five meters away he's
gotta four times is super fast Wow oh
that is hilarious
oh man I want him to shoot bullets
please please attack range
oh yes range Dinis have attack range of
30 meters at 50 meters 50 meters is good
live wild man now live wild man where's
wild man custom Wow please please tough
to get wild man is now a glorious part
of this battle what's that on the hill
wild man all right hang on
there hey hey shut the [ __ ] up got wild
man coming in having Knights versus
works that seems like a good battle that
seems like it might be a good battle
okay all right I'm down look out for
this oh oh I shouldn't have made it more
orcs I thought the orcs weren't going to
be as tough all right I'm ready
what's happening here oh it's on
cinematic mode I forgot about that
[Applause]
oh god Wildman wait pan turns into manic
moto
where's Wildman Wow is he doing it
farm chair okay possess him and I'm
gonna whoa
Wildman you've seen better days
rubber hell scare scare scare scare
scare scare scare scare scare scare
scare scare scare scare scare scare
scare scare kids
[Music]
goddamn hero what a [ __ ] hero
Wildman go get bug you're missing
Wildman but and I expect that boom
aiming ain't too easy
[Applause]
there's quite a while it's just two big
clumps of body slamming into each other
so I guess that's a thing I can't tell
you who's winning over the orcs winning
you can't tell once again big boy over
here shootin bullets out of his nose
that's old now Wildman you keep up with
it you're doing great buddy you're doing
beyond great you're doing wonderful even
Oh seems like the Knights have won do
too wild man's careful assistance oh god
they're being boxed in yeah if they want
to take in some strategy here actually
let me put it you take some strategies
oh no no no
and then go to position
that's a better stratagem and then carry
on everything buddy smooth see that's
better now you're [ __ ] up oh my god
[Applause]
and this is a pile of bodies I had no
idea oh that's awesome
that's a lot of butts that's a lot of
bodies that is a lot of bodies how do
they simulate that that's awesome and
love that so shooting out of his myth so
I think this battle is won even though
they're fighting each other
I think that's it for this episode I
think we did well here so I'll turn
cinematic mode on so uh yeah thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see another cool battle let me
know down in the comments below I'll try
to come up with some new ideas on my own
the Sun is setting on this lovely
battlefield and uh the knights and wild
men have won so thank you again
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]